i just don't think people should pay for
tampons so she can get like poor kids in
school that are using like tissue paper
with tampons because they can't tell you
for president
prime minister it's your girl tony t
just call me audrey
we are the receipts podcast and we are
going to be doing the
bestie test we met on twitter we met
with the aim to start a podcast yeah it
was podcast first finish it later yeah
everyone's got similar stories we're
kind of around the same age for me i was
just excited i was like yeah i've got
these new girls in my life and it's just
fun
[Music]
imagine yourselves at a party
where would you find me in the middle
doing a dance battle
[Music]
tally would be at home on her way
i have to nap before any party or i
won't have a good time yeah i'll be on
my way on her way yeah that's about the
answer what is the hill
i will die on
i know yeah there's one really obvious
colorism yeah like i said like you are
big on it
100 spot on
something that's really close to my
heart yeah i'm really really passionate
about it and i just feel like i just
have to use my voice to speak up on it
and i'm really big on cancelling people
that have been involved in in any way
and if they've done anything remotely
colouristic lots of black women like i
don't mess with them yeah at all
if i found myself in jail what would be
my crime well i know the exact situation
right you would be with someone right
find out they've done something and then
you being bigger black i want to go talk
to the girl next thing you know then you
get in your car
try to damage her stuff
what is my biggest pet peeve
i have so many that's the thing there
are so many people that are just act
like kind of slow for no reason lack of
sharpness
gumption lack of energy
be about something have something i hate
when it's not man like i don't know
people yeah
you need to do something go with urgency
and with like know who you are
yeah
okay girls what would give me the ick
maybe somebody's taking you somewhere
where you didn't want to go on the first
date would that give you the ear i think
someone badly dressed i think if they
wore something that was like well who's
still wearing those jeans yeah i i think
the dress one that's really really
dress sense is really important to me
and if you've rocked up
dressed dodgy
what is my alcoholic drink of choice my
nephew gin and tonic i like both but now
we've recently he wins not that it's not
yeah what was the last one what's the
last stinky drink oh reina
i do love a gin because of you yeah gina
told you i love a giant tonic i am this
close to making gym my personality type
i want to start saying jim i thought you
meant june
[Music]
oh this is hard this is hard everyone's
funny i think audrey is the funniest you
have a great life i tell actual jokes
i am
yeah i agree yeah i think you've got
really good leadership qualities
like there's loads of things to think
about but i think the tampon situation
that we're in i just don't think people
should pay for tampons especially less
fortunate it spins me every single time
so she can get like poor kids in school
that are using like tissue paper with
tampons because they can't i could go
into it for ages
[Laughter]
is
and i know information about everybody
yeah or anyone yeah that's very true
yeah it's actually me let me take that
yeah
if they was absolutely sure that i
wouldn't die
yeah i would yeah but if there's a
smidge of a chance
i'm not doing it unless it's like a
fight that someone's got into and we're
all back in it that audrey went back i
went so many of you got sorry
putting it out there
without a doubt definitely
yeah no but you know what i wouldn't now
i would do everything i need to do and
my man will just be there and i'll do i
don't know actually maybe i mean i do
like men but you know what i mean like
that
not that much
you change your hair the most i chose
yeah yeah you do yeah i'm big on being
high maintenance i think everyone should
be high maintenance are you low
maintenance or why you just used to
neglect
i'm so funny man
i want to thank these two
[Laughter]